All right, welcome back to the program.
We're taking calls today via discord for the
first time.
And I have to tell you, David Pakman dot com
slash discord, it really has improved audio
quality dramatically.
We're continuing our tour of the world.
Next, we are going to go to MEECO from Finland.
I love Finland.
I had the pleasure of being there last year.
It was an amazing experience.
MEECO Where in Finland are you and what's
on your mind today?
Hi, David, it's, uh.
It's dark here and it's cold and on my mind,
it is that the your country seems to be on
the words of civil war and at the end of democracy.
Yes, very clear.
Your assessment from Finland is accurate.
Thank you.
No.
What do you think if things do get violent
and to get out of hand and fall into anarchy?
What good pointers could you give to people
to do on how to react and what to do if the
anarchy breaks out?
I don't know the answer to that.
You know, I have friends on the left who never
considered getting firearms before, who were
never preppers, who now have firearms.
They are very, very scared about the possibility
for violence.
I, I don't know what to advise people to do.
My my hope is that state National Guards are
not going to allow violence incited by Donald
Trump to take over states.
I cannot imagine, you know, we have a Republican
governor here in Massachusetts, Charlie Baker,
despite being a Republican, Charlie Baker
refused to send any National Guard down to
the border when Donald Trump wanted to use
the National Guard down there.
My belief is if it really came to it, and
I hope it doesn't, that Charlie Baker is going
to use the state National Guard to protect
against the violence that Donald Trump may
be wanting to incite.
But I am as much in debt in the dark, metaphorically,
Mieko, as you are saying, Finland is in the
dark from the standpoint of light, because
I don't know what's going to happen.
OK.
Thank you.
That's a good answer.
Then another word that I have found that is
very descriptive of your country at the moment.
These cookies, ocracy carcass statues.
Yes.
Yes, Richard.
Which I think that is.
Well, it means that the country is governed
by the least qualified.
Do you agree?
It's it's hard to find people less qualified
than Trump.
Yeah, I mean, I was thinking, you know, I
think back to my college professors earlier
this week, I interviewed Richard Wolffe.
Okay.
Richard Wolff is a socialist.
A lot of people aren't socialists.
Richard Wolffe would have handled the pandemic
better than Donald Trump.
I think back to I ran into a high school English
teacher over the weekend.
My high school English teacher dropped in
to deal with Corona virus, would have handled
it better than Donald Trump merely by deferring
to experts.
It's hard to imagine short of someone who
is truly cognitively disabled.
Straight up disabled of people that would
be worst suited to be in charge right now.
You're you're absolutely correct.
I'm so sorry that it's come to this.
Go over to the next hope for the next one.
Nico, listen, what would you have to offer?
What part of Finland are you in?
I'm about one hour drive away from Helsinki
downtown, and it's a little bit over one hour
by car.
And we're very a cell phone.
OK.
Well, I love Helsinki.
There is this.
Are you familiar with this salmon soup?
That is very typical of Helsinki.
Yes, I am.
Well, someone soup is actually very typical
of all of Finland.
What a what a dish.
What a delightful dish.
I just I must have had that 10 times when
I was in Finland.
Absolutely delicious.
Most are here.
Yeah.
All right, Mieko, I appreciate you calling
in.
And I hope to be back in Finland before too
long.
We'll come.
All right.
There it is, Mieko.
What a friendly guy.
People are just so friendly in in Finland.